[Music]
[Applause]
we get nominated for awards this guy
wins Awards Bryant Gumbel host of HBO's
Real Sports and former co-host on today
he is going to be presented with the
Lifetime Achievement Award at this
year's Sports Emmys that'll be coming up
in New York City on May 22nd right good
to see you how many Emmys do you have
oh God I I don't know I honestly don't
know Dan um I I mean the shows on which
I've worked um I'm gonna guess it's
close to 58 or something like that where
do you put them
I I don't I really don't that's the
truth um I'm sitting in my home in
Florida right now and I must honestly
tell you there's not a one of them here
here
um I I keep some in New York
um I I don't I honestly don't know where
most of them are I really don't it
doesn't doesn't mean I'm not
appreciative just means that I'm not I'm
not real big on
I shouldn't say that I'm not I'm not
terribly being on Awards I've never been
concerned how about you and Bob Costas
do like a yard sale just
out there because because Bob's got
quite a few of them too yeah I know he's
got a bunch I think it just means we're
both getting up in years I mean as
usually happens when you when you when
you live long enough you collect a lot
of stuff
what's your first real vivid sports
memory
oh wow real vivid sports memory I'm
gonna say
Chicago Bears
E3 NFL Championship at Wrigley Field
beat the Giants 14-10.
um I I wound up getting tickets to that
game because at a holy name society
meeting that morning I'd gone with my
dad and Joe Fortunato if you can believe
this before the championship game was a
guest at a holy name society breakfast
and he had two tickets for anybody who
asked a decent question and I was a kid
and I asked something stupid and
everybody else was too embarrassed to
ask a dumb question and so I got the
tickets and I went to the game
and that's my most Vivid number
did it change your life
not really I I I don't think so I mean I
I was a kid I suspect like you who grew
up you know not only playing a lot of
stuff but but when you couldn't go
outside play stratomatic baseball all
the time
I've never ate PBA I always tried him
out I love stradomatic yeah it was good
stuff I was playing stratomatic when I
was at ESPN come on serious swear to God
yeah
yeah wow yeah I know I gave up on it I I
think
um After High School
um I I almost gave up on it because I
had a friend named John Miller Once Upon
a Time who
um we had a league of stratomatic and
one night I walked by his room and I
heard dice rolling and he was giving his
guys batting practice that's what I
thought I really should get out of it
but it helped me
So when you say hey what kind of Fielder
was Rusty stop waves of four or Ralph
Garr wasn't a good Fielder uh you know
uh who would it be Aurelio Rodriguez
would be a one so it yeah it just helped
me understand everything about a player
and you know I just absorbed all that
information whether it was going to be
useful or not you could also cheat at
the margins like like I remember back
then the guy you wanted to put in your
lineup all the time was Merit renewed of
the Cubs who had hit something like 363
but it only had like 40 at bets
and even Joe Torre I remember when Joe
won a batting title he had like 362 or
something 63 wasn't it 363. yeah yeah
yeah it was it was great
where are we the state of Journalism in
sports now is what to you
um tough to come by
I mean I you you know you know it as
well as I do I mean but what reality is
because because as is the answer with
all things in sports the money
um every steam house now has a um a
television arm you have the you know the
NBA network you have MLB Network
um and so as a result I think anytime
anybody gets in trouble they can go to
that Network and expect a softer Landing
than they would if they had to face
either you or me you know on a neutral
site
um
um given the opportunity to to craft
their own narrative
um they're they're able to to go on the
air there they're able to to use social
media to get out their version of the
truth and it makes it more difficult for
those of us who who work in this
business to try to to elicit honest
answers in an honest form but also you
have the programming now where it's a
hot take gotta have a hot take and I
just I'm mean I'm a dinosaur I always
say I'm going to have an informed taker
best I can it might not be a hot take it
might be lukewarm it may not be warm at
all but my God if you're a dinosaur what
does that make me well
you're a pterodactyl too but but
that's how kids are kind of absorbing
this business of that's what you need to
have because for a while when I was
doing SportsCenter you had to have a
catchphrase yeah you gotta have a catch
now it's you gotta have a hot take and
it leads us leads us down dangerous
paths here sure it does sure it does and
then by the way you know I don't I don't
I don't really blame the athletes I
guess if I were in the spotlight that
they're in I'd be looking for the
softest Landing possible I mean I figure
why the hell do I need Brian gumbler Dan
Patrick you know I can craft my own
narrative I can put it out on the
players Tribune I can go to my my team's
network if you happen to play for the
Yankees or the you know
um or any other big Market team
um and you can get a a softer Landing
than you would in your studio or mine
I'm in there they're not dumb what's the
uh segment or show that you got the most
blowback on
wow there have been a bunch of them I
mean whenever we do anything
um transgender we get a lot of it
um whenever we do anything where um race
or women's rights is are involved we get
a lot of it
um a lot of people as you know all the
time are inclined to say I don't want
any politics in my sports well I'm not
necessarily sure human rights ever
deserves to be called politics I mean um
you know that has nothing to do with
politics trying to save a life trying to
make someone's life better to me that's
devoid of politics but we live in the
world in which we live explain to me how
the show works from the standpoint of
your involvement during a segment like
you send Andrea Kramer out
and she does a story on the voice of
hockey night in America and then comes
back are you are you involved in what
she does prior to it getting back
getting on the air and then her sitting
in the studio with you to a certain
extent every step of the way
um but varying degrees
um you know yes
um stories are green lit
um and every step of the way
um if I don't like something I make it
known but in my micromanaging no I mean
I I've said from the start that I didn't
want every piece to look like it was a
Bryant Gumbel piece
um so I try to make sure that um all of
our producers who I think the world of
um have as much free range as possible
there are very few things that I'll step
up and go hey you know what that really
makes me uncomfortable we're not going
to do that we're not going to go there
but also and and also by the way I'll
add this too Dan to show you we're
talking about being being a dinosaur
um I've had the fight and so far I've
won the fight for 29 years
um I wish I could tell you how many
people want us to introduce music to our
pieces
um and and and I'm always I've brought
up in an era where once you introduce
music now you're manipulating the
audience now you're not doing journalism
you're doing movie making and and so I I
continue to resist but I also get the
feeling you're acting as a viewer you're
seeing this for the first time and your
reaction is in real time
and I don't know if that's if that's by
accident or not no it's not by accident
it's absolutely true
um every correspondent that's ever
worked for us will tell you that
um I I never ever had a conversation
with them about the finished product
before we're on air so they have no idea
what I'm going to ask them and and and
again my my questions are really I'm
trying to give voice to what I think the
viewer wants to know sometimes they're
very crass things like how much do they
get paid for doing that yes
um does he have a family stupid stuff
he's Bryant Gumbel Real Sports with
Brent Gumbel and being honored Lifetime
Achievement Award this year's Sports
Emmys that'll be in New York City on May
22nd what do you remember most in the
moment about Bird versus magic in the
national title game
um I remember looking around and going
wow this really should be a I wish this
was a larger gymnasium
um it was it was this it remains I think
it was the last small venue right
I'm gonna guess yeah I don't know what
that seeded but that was what Salt Lake
City yeah Salt Lake City is 79 I'm gonna
guess there couldn't have been more than
14 000 people if that
you know
um I I always try to trick people up
with this question everybody remembers
that it was Indiana State Michigan State
few people can name the other two teams
in that final four
DePaul and Princeton you got it Rob
winebauer and and Mark McGuire yes wait
was it was it DePaul Princeton or DePaul
and Penn Paul and Penn Bob why not okay
okay Bob weiner pen all right and uh Ray
Meyer and Mark McGuire yes
yeah but did you understand the you know
what that was going to mean
yeah you know
you know I mean I don't think it took a
genius but yes I think anybody
who understood
and it understood the the Allure of
these two special players uh would have
been an idiot not to not to appreciate
the impact and and foresee that they
were going to change the the NBA I mean
if you you'll recall as well as I did
back then the NBA uh was not a very
popular sport
um it wasn't a niche sport by any means
but it wasn't as popular as it is today
because it was kind of a given go sport
you know give it to me and go to hell
um and these two guys uh may pass first
a priority and once they went to the NBA
they took that kind of magic no pun
intended
um to the game and and I think changed
it enormously and for the better
who do you want to sit down with
wow what a great question
um you know I mean look it's The Usual
Suspects the guys who are resistant to
to doing interviews I'd like to sit with
Steve Cohen
um I know I'm with we we've had you know
we've sat socially with their dinners
um but I'd like to sit down with them
with a microphone on I'd like to sit
down with Aaron Rodgers
um pick his brain I'd like to sit down
with um Ben Simmons find out why he
really doesn't like basketball
um I I can think of of quite a few
really
how hard is it to not go in with a
preconceived idea when you do an
interview
damn near impossible damn near
impossible you know what Dan uh you know
as well as I do people say well you know
your journalists you have preconceived
notions about everything and I always
say there's there's no such thing as as
pure objectivity we are all
um products of of our environment and
our experience
and and I guess the trick to the
business is try mightily to not let
those
um dictate
um your questions or your opinions of
what you're hearing
um I I've always thought that that the
thing about interviewing is very very
simple I've told people over and over
again
um I'm doing I'm nothing more than there
to
um ask questions that I think viewers
want to heard want to your answers and
make you clarify or Justify
your answer and that's it that's it it's
very simple stuff there's some
interviews that stand out in fact HBO
sent some interviews that you did and
you know a list of them and they didn't
include Nolan Richardson and I thought
it was one of the best ones you've ever
done because
you let him talk and a lot of
interviewers don't let people talk and
the questions were open-ended and and I
tell people a lot of times
that in the interview that Andrea Kramer
did with uh the guy who started Bikram I
thought that piece that Andrew did is
one of the best journalistic pieces that
I've ever seen in all of my years that
guy was dangerous yes but she let him
show you and tell you that he was
dangerous and I thought what you were
getting out of Nolan Richardson was was
great because I felt like I was just
listening and you weren't guiding him
anywhere and it just made for a
compelling interview and that and that's
a that's a hard thing to do because we
always get in the way of our interviews
it feels like you're a smart you're a
smart guy and that's usually what works
you know my my tried answer when people
always say you know who are the good
interviews and who are the bad ones I
always say it's pretty simple that the
good interview is somebody who has
something to say and says it well
the bad one is the guy who has nothing
to say and says it for you
um in the case of Nolan Richardson he
had a lot to say and he said it well I
don't need to do anything yeah it's it's
hard for us to get out of our own way
all right the final question and I
should have led with this it's the most
important question that I'll probably
ever ask you oh I feel it in my plums go
ahead are you ready
I want you to tell us what you write
down on your pad at the end of every
show Brian
um you know I I get it a lot I'm never
going to answer it um a lot of times
it's doodling a lot of times it's things
that are going through my head sometimes
it's a simple thing of a reminder of
somebody's name
okay
because I'm sure you've had those where
where you come to the back end of a
sentence and you know what word you want
to use it just doesn't go in the file
cabinet rapidly enough well I would do
that on SportsCenter when I would get
done because you're on camera well what
do you do on camera and then I you know
you have to shuffle your paper they
teach you this when you get started
shuffle your paper and then I started
writing down something just to kind of
mock you I'm like well Brian's doing it
I'm just gonna write down something I'm
not going to say anything I might even
draw a picture of phallic symbol or
something but you know I I had to do
something every night doing SportsCenter
for 200 days out of the year
because your hands are here right here
that's the other thing when they fade to
Blacken Your Shadow is still there what
are you supposed to do just sit there
like this you have to do something and I
also loved tomorrow on today
and yeah PostScript
those are yeah and fine let's move on
We're All Creatures yes and finally a
post group uh hey congrats Brian yeah
hey thanks very much yeah it's always a
pleasure yeah it's good it's good to see
you thanks for your healthy healthy and
happy
keep uh how's the golf game by the way
actually you know what's weird I can't
figure this out I'm coming up I'm 75
years old and I'm playing better than I
have in the last decade I can't figure
it out
do you care less therefore you might
play better
good question
um no I I think I'm you know it's taken
me a long time to do this I think I Now
understand that the importance of the
game is making a score not how you look
doing it and and and getting your ego
out of the way
I think that's I always thought that was
Jordan's problem with baseball he wanted
to look good
and and instead of just you might not
look good but but you could still be
somewhat successful but Mike wanted his
swing to look really good but it was
really slow and you don't know he could
have had a Paul Molitor swing and and
you know maybe been a decent baseball
player yeah yeah I get it but the things
look look at the pictures Clementi and
Beres oh yeah yeah all right uh well
congrats again and maybe we'll see you
maybe we'll see there you know we
getting eliminated we get nominated we
don't win but you know I don't
understand that if I need to be a seat
filler I'll be right when they go in
lifetime achievement let's hey guys
let's practice here lifetime achievement
awards
yeah
thank you Brian thanks Dan that's right
Gumbel he's getting a Lifetime
Achievement Award Sports Emmys